any one of these watches to any of you
which one would you take in the comments
which one would you take I think this is
going to win you think the one of a kind
a I think that's going to win I think
this and this will be a joint second
what a great contest any one you want
you tell me what it is before we end
today I have to tell you about a new
project I've got one of the biggest
challenges I have is how do I ensure
these watches these are traveling with
me a dozen here and two here every one
of these are insured while they're on
the Road I created Wonder care.com to
solve for my collection as it travels
all around the world ware.com check it
out